have you ever
given guys advice no you've never given
guys advice not really
no one because they don't ask actually i
have one guy that requested me for a 101
but and i did do it for him but it was
more like
i didn't even really know what he wanted
to talk about he's just like 50 bucks
half hour of your time i was like okay
okay i have a question you have a son
uh-huh
what are three things you would teach
them about women
i'd be like one i know they're pretty
but
be careful son
no i want something specific uh wear a
condom
[Music]
okay don't get the wrong [ __ ] pregnant
i swear to god you come home pregnant
i'm not helping you
um don't believe her she's on birth
control i don't care how nice she is you
never know
that's true um
but that goes back to it is it her
responsibility to his responsibility
i would say it's mostly hers because
again no woman can carry a child that
she does not take to term
but don't give her that power son don't
don't give her that power um two
i would say
look for a girl that has the same values
as you
that's really important
um three
pay attention to how attention seeking
she is
especially and pay attention to
how she acts around your friends when
you're not around
how are you going to see how she asks
around your friends you ask your friends
yeah
yeah have your friend flirt with her a
little bit see what she does so throw a
little test away
yeah how often do girls do that a lot
they throw a text to their friend's
boyfriend oh no not oh
wait
wait wait what was the alarm
um let me think so the
but
i
haven't heard too many people do like a
loyalty test to their boyfriends
i meant like i've seen a lot of girls
flirt with like guys when their
boyfriends aren't around that's what i
meant
you wait you've seen a lot of
girls flirt with guys uh-huh yeah like
so say
um you guys are dating okay and you're
like
bye babe have fun
and then you leave then she starts
seeking attention from like another guy
and they're like
like
yeah yeah
so i've seen i've seen that a lot i see
that
a lot
is that because they're interested or
they just want attention
do you think i would say like 50 50.
yeah i mean i don't just see if they can
yeah i don't think some of them like
wouldn't actually do it
but
it's like
do you want a girl that's like acting
like that when you're not around and it
also it comes to um
emotional infidelity physical infidelity
and like there's the the big sort of
argument that a lot of people is like so
if you're at a bar and you flirt with a
man for free drinks would your man be
okay with it or would he not and i know
some guys who are like yeah girl go for
it give me get me a free drink yeah i
know some guys especially but i know
girls who will be out with their man and
a man will flirt with them and they'll
be like yeah like
get me a drink get me two drinks and
then they'll literally take it and be
like this is me my boyfriend and the
boyfriend will be there like you're
welcome but then i know other men who
literally i think that's ass i would not
do it if a man hit on me and i had a man
i'd literally would be like leave me the
[ __ ] alone i don't care how good you're
making me feel i'd be like no thank you
no no no like oh it makes me feel really
uncomfortable but i know there are some
women who are very comfortable doing it
and some men who are comfortable with a
woman doing it and i'm like that is
confusing i would say
i would say if she is doing it where it
is an asset to him
fair game because i've had it where like
a girl got free [ __ ] and she's like i
got this from this guy was hitting on me
although i should i thought you'd like
like this i was like all right i'll take
it
actually i have a question for you going
in have you ever taken back a cheater
no never
i wouldn't i'd forgive them
but yeah if they cheated me it's a wrap
but i think it's different for guys
i think it's different
i know a lot of guys have taken back
cheaters
really why do you think they took them
back i think they could do better
so they took them back because of
scarcity
probably
i don't know why else you would well so
yeah
i i literally can't think of another
reason you'd if you thought you could do
better like
like that's it's like um
yeah scarcity
yeah yeah i think it's because it's like
i think it's hard to find people you
actually like you have to go through a
lot of like people till you find one you
like
yeah
like in general
what
you do
you said you said the other day you like
you like you're not that funny
i'm not that full of people fond of
people
didn't you say that the other day
did i no i love people i'm like i'm a
chit chatter oh yeah you are yeah
i just i'm i'm i said i'm picky with who
i date
oh maybe that's what it was really for
sure like yeah yeah like like i wouldn't
date someone liberal but i'm like
friends like all my friends
like
yeah liberals are fun